(mystic guitar music)
(grunting)
- [Narrator] Mayan dances are a huge part
of Guatemalan history and religion.
(grunting)
In the ancient ritual
of the deer dance, it's
particularly important.
(crackling)
(mystic guitar music)
(whistling)
(rhythmic drumming)
- [Narrator] The Feast of Corpus Christi,
celebrated on May 31st,
is a huge Catholic holiday
in Central and South American countries.
Guatemala is no exception.
There, it's a celebration
filled with tradition, ritual and dance.
As part of the holiday,
the villagers of Patzún
come together to put on the deer dance.
Juan Yool Gómez has been
participating in the dance
for over 20 years, but this tradition
goes back much farther than that.
(crackling)
(murmuring)
(playful music)
(grunting)
- [Narrator] The deer dance
represents a deer hunt.
It's intending to show how
humans and other animals
have had to coexist in
nature throughout history.
(whistling)
(mystic music)
(grunting)
(pretty stringed music)
(rhythmic drumming)
(sonic beep)